i'm just gonna  drop everything and i'm just gonna allow  myself to obsess i just started reading  and watching everything listen to only  his music and i just treat it as though  i already had the job somebody who is so  iconic and who everybody knows and so  many people have paid tribute to or  impersonated and it's hard not to feel  like a little kid in your dad's suit  like you're wearing these really big  shoes that you can hardly walk in he was  such an extraordinary human being that  he almost seems superhuman larger than  life itself that's something that i've  had so many people help me with over  this process i mean and it's been that  thing of how do you climb mount everest  but just one step at a time